thank you to ancestry for supporting pbs
if you are a fan of science fiction a
name you should be familiar with
is octavia e butler especially if you
watched our
tele award-winning afrofuturism video
starring me
one of the most prolific and important
black authors in the genre
butler storytelling pushed the
boundaries of what black people were
allowed to be
in science fiction today we will be
highlighting the grand
dom herself and how her novels were
important
and sometimes oddly predictive
like super friggin predictive
[Music]
octavia estelle butler was born in
pasadena california
in 1947. her father died when she was a
toddler and she was raised by her
grandmother and mother
in what she would recall as a very
strict baptist environment
that religious experience would come up
often in her work
especially in the parable series butler
would describe herself as
awkward introverted and painfully shy
which led to her being picked on by her
fellow classmates growing up which you
know
every nerdy black girl story you're
preaching to the choir there octavia
later she would describe herself in the
following self-deprecating way
who am i uh a pessimist if i'm not
careful
a feminist a black a former baptist
an oil and water combination of ambition
laziness insecurity certainty
and drive honestly that could be my
gender profile
thumbs up if you agree despite being
pushed by her mother to find a more
secure job
butler pursued her writing goals she
participated in the open door workshop
of the writers guild of america west
a program designed to specifically
mentor minority writers
and butler ended up impressing science
fiction author
harlan ellison he encouraged her to
attend the six-week science fiction
writers workshop in pennsylvania
where she met fellow black sci-fi author
samuel
r delany after selling some short
stories in 1971
she would spend the following five years
writing what would become the patternist
series
it was with the release of that series
that she finally became
a full-time author the dream
and subsequently in 1979 she published
what is probably her most famous novel
kindred kindred tells the story of an
african-american woman
named dana franklin who for reasons we
never really find out
is pulled back in time to a pre-civil
war maryland plantation
on her first journey there she meets her
ancestors
alice greenwood a black freed woman
and rufus whalen a white planter who
will eventually force alice into slavery
and sexual servitude
danish trips into the past range from
one moment
to years and each trip does substantial
harm to her mind and spirit
especially having to deal with the harsh
reality that
her existence is part of this dark
legacy of sexual violence it would be
one of the many times butler would
address the legacy of slavery
in the science fiction element madu
dubai
professor of english and afro-american
studies at the university of illinois
at chicago said of butler in common with
other contemporary african american
writers
butler persistently revisit slavery in
order to challenge the redemptive
accounts of u.s racial history
that began to gain sway in the decades
following the civil rights movement
yet in a distinct departure from the
neo-slave narrative genre
the signifier of slavery in butler's
novels
mutates to refer to a range of abusive
practices
such as sexual trafficking reproductive
oppression
and debt bondage which are not reducible
to race
even when race does operate as a central
axis of inequality in butler's novels of
enslavement
it far exceeds the binary black and
white logic
bequeathed by the institution of shadow
slavery
these themes are most obvious in kindred
but pop up throughout her work such as
in the paranist series where
an ancient human with the ability to
body snatch people
basically breeds his own descendants
like cattle
in the pursuit of creating a new
post-human
species which okay
or the xenogenesis trilogy wherein after
the earth blows itself up in a nuclear
armageddon
possible some aliens show up and force
what's left of humanity
to breed with each other and also the
aliens
don't know why but okay
tragically butler's life was cut short
when she died at the age of 58 in 2006.
the novel fledgling a story about a
vampire that was changed very young
was published posthumously octavia e
butler is what we would call a certified
genius and her work has resonated so
powerfully
because of themes and imagery she was
able to
bring together yet when people talk
about sci-fi and blackness together
it is treated as some anomaly
something that butler herself would talk
about in her essay birth of a writer
first published in essence there seems
to be an unwritten rule
hurtful and at odds with the realities
of american
culture it says you aren't supposed to
wonder
whether as a black person a black
woman you really might be inferior
not quite bright enough not quite quick
enough
not quite good enough to do the things
you want to do
act tough and confident and don't
talk about your doubts if you never deal
with them
you may never get rid of them but no
matter
fake everyone out even yourself
while all her novels and short stories
have a lot we could discuss
we decided to focus on the parable
novels because
there's nothing like living in your own
dystopia to really
make things come into focus if you get
what i mean released in 1993
one year after i was born so it was a
present for me
parable of the sower takes place in the
distant future
of 2024. when society in the united
states and our
favorite unholy trinity of climate
change
wealth inequality and corporate greed
has
ravaged the nation leaving it in a state
of pure
dystopia how
fantasiful and unrealistic i know
we start this journey with the main
character of lauren an african-american
teenager who details everything in a
journal
she has a condition called hyperempathy
where she feels the emotions of
others due to the side effects of a drug
her late mother took while pregnant
lauren lives with her father stepmother
and three half-brothers
in the remains of a gated community in
california throughout the first part of
the novel she and her community
struggled to maintain any sense of
civilization against the mad max world
outside where rape torture
violence and pure anarchy
are allowed to take place police
officers and firefighters exploit their
positions taking bribes for profit
and do very little to actually serve and
protect the community
lauren's father a baptist preacher has
been trying to keep their community
civilized
and collaborative through democratic
socialism
excuse me excuse me sorry that was my
propaganda showing um
i mean sharing of resources and
investing
in mutual aids for each other totally
not democratic socialism
still lauren can tell this is only a
temporary thing in response to darkness
surrounding her she starts the religion
earth seed
based on the concept god is
change god is change this is the literal
truth
a god cannot be resisted or stopped but
can be shaped and focused
this means god is not to be prayed to
prayers only help the person during the
praying
and then only if they strengthen and
focus
that person's resolve if they're used
that way
they can help us in our only real
relationship with god
they help us to shape god and to accept
and work with the shapes
that god imposes on us god is power
and in the end god prevails after her
family and most of her community are
destroyed and burnt down
lauren begins to travel north and along
the way builds a congregation through
mutual aid
and assistance the second novel parable
of the talents takes place
five years after the previous novel
america has become controlled by a
christian fundamentalist
denomination called christian america
led by president andrew steele jarrett a
totally normal name
despite the optimistic ending of the
first book we see laura and her
followers deal with an even darker
america
john blair gamber professor of english
at utah state university says of this
theme
while sower appears to have a utopian
conclusion talents irrefutably shows it
to be dystopian
a failure of misguided idealism
specifically the implicit critique of
anti-urbanism in flight
that comprise the pastoral impulse and
aesthetic we see in
sower becomes explicit in talents the
primary failure of this
impulse comes in the protagonist's
inability to recognize her role
within a wide-reaching community or her
fundamental connection to
local and distant structures of power
oppression and marginalization
president jarrett's presidency is filled
with death
and torture as he if you can believe
this
as he wants to restore americans power
on the global stage
and he actually literally uses the
slogan
make america great again
jared brings back slavery with shock
collars being used
to control people and restarts witch
hunts in order to wipe out
non-christian religions virtual reality
headsets called dream masks
also become very popular since they
enable wares to escape their harsh
reality and okay
now who's messing with me who copied
this timeline
into the nexus and can you control z it
earth seed as of faith continues to
spread and develop
and despite the violence that is
depicted eventually after one term
president jarrett is not re-elected
yay okay that also attracts that's fine
that's good
humanity then begins its expansion into
the stars
carrying with it the ideas that lauren
started
at the end of the novel she watches the
first of earth starships leave
and the ship is called the christopher
columbus
sigh lauren says in the book's
conclusion
i object to the name this ship is not
about a shortcut to riches
and empire it is not about snatching up
slaves
and gold and presenting them to some
european monarch
but one cannot win every battle one must
know which battles to fight
even the utopian society she is
constructing starts off with a little
chrome of colonization
addressing that nothing can truly detach
humanity from
that sin especially when tied to the
united states
scholar jim miller in post-apocalyptic
hoping
octavia butler's dystopian utopian
vision
said as an african-american woman riding
within a largely white woman's tradition
her work often questions the assumptions
shared by many
white women utopian writers butler is
far more class conscious than many other
utopian feminist science fiction writers
thus her largely utopian fictions
challenge not
only patriarchal myths but also
capitalist myths racist myths and
feminist utopian myths butler herself
doesn't seem to care much for utopias
and
said as much during an interview in 1988
with larry mccaffrey and jim mcmenamin
i find utopia is ridiculous we're not
going to have a perfect society
until we get a few perfect humans and
that
seems unlikely besides any true utopia
would almost certainly be incredibly
boring
and it would probably be so over
specialized
that any change we might introduce would
probably
destroy the whole system as bad as we
humans are sometimes i have a feeling
that we'll never have that problem with
the current system
these themes are woven throughout
butler's body of work which as
complex and often challenging questions
about the nature of autonomy
and how it interacts with community and
usually with no clear answers
but butler's work uses science fiction
to advocate for a more
just world despite knowing full well
that the road to get there
won't be easy nor like lauren not
personally leaving earth to see
manny spread beyond the stars would she
live to see it
jim miller writes that the ideal for
butler seems to be a society
which respects individual differences
but not at the expense of the greater
good of society as a whole
the achievements of the collective good
should not require the neglect of
individual autonomy
nor should the price of freedom be the
inevitable deprivation
of the weakest among us octavia e butler
is a name that has only grown in esteem
in the past few years as black
authorship in science fiction and
fantasy
has only expanded regardless of how you
feel about her work
because boy can it get dark at times
she laid the foundation through which
contemporary afrofuturists stand upon
she was bold and brave in her blackness
and the way in which her stories feel so
modern is a testament to her
own genius and creativity taken
much too soon there is no telling how
much she could have
done if she were alive today still
writing and still pushing black people
to the stars thank you to ancestry for
supporting pbs
was that your great grandmother keeping
the family together was that your
great-grandfather paving the way for
change
did they brave mother nature and walk
away stronger
did they face the unknown with resolve
and triumph
there is strength in every family story
ancestry can help you learn about yours
visit ancestry.com for more information